we always have a good time at the show
and actually something fun and special
happened last week i don't know if you
saw adam pally but he came by and during
the interview basically just gave me
for about 20 minutes just gave me a real
steady stream of
uh and then at the end of the interview
my producer told me that for editing
purposes we had to reshoot the ending
this actually happened we had to reshoot
the ending and to make it look natural i
had to fake laugh
and then say we'll be right back or if
that's our show good night and that was
like the most uncomfortable i've ever
been on the show
in a studio where everybody knew i was
about to fake just just watch you'll see
would you say my ankles
i think that that will screw up the
whole point of what we're doing oh i
could
is that what i've looked like this whole
time
okay here we go
i can't believe you have to do that
it's horrible it's horrible
i sound like a lunatic
you look like one too cause in your eyes
you're trying to build it up so it's
genuine
adam valley everybody we'll be right
back
oh lunatic pleaty i did my best it's not
it's not
it's not easy